hey guys what's going on welcome to
another video concerning
trading of bitcoin um this is gonna be
the
second part in this series and what
we're gonna be talking about in this
video
is the risks associated with
um trading bitcoin uh
in the background i'll just put the same
chart i had on the first one it's just
the chart of the mount gox
btc usd price compared to
uh btc dashes btc usd
price at the moment we're seeing them
really
at least right here they're very similar
all through normally
you're going to see that they have a
large gap and measured down here is
actually the gap
so this is what you'll typically see is
a big gap like this size
and not so small like this so it's kind
of interesting to see that they're so
uh closely knit at the moment
our arbitragers are pissed anyway
um so on to risk uh and again just i'll
point out
you know we've got a high here of about
765
and a low here so it went from 765 and
about
15 minutes to 680 so a massive drop
within about a 15 minute
period and then again it hung down here
for a little bit and spiked all the way
up
um to about 7 30 ish but also if you
looked
at and that was mount gox though if you
look at btc
it was a little more stable so it went
just from 720 to 690 and then back up
again but even 720 to 690 and then back
up against pretty
uh pretty serious swings and this is
this chart here it just
only is an hour so as we get a plot here
it knocks off a plot back here
and it continues that way at the top
here obviously we have the relative
strength
index and on the bottom the macd
anyway this video is all about the risk
so the first
risk pretty much covered here volatility
um so the market for bitcoin consists
mainly of speculators right
most of you guys that are interested in
this video even are speculators and
pretty much
everybody in the market is a speculator
there's actually very few businesses
on the whole that actually deal in
bitcoin
and a lot of the major ones are just
kind of criminal websites
and they eventually do get shut down so
you wouldn't want to like put all your
eggs in that basket so
um so most of these people are just
speculators interested maybe
making a quick buck or even trading it
but they don't represent
anything but short-term holding and so
this causes really extreme volatility
the other issue causing the volatility
is the trading fees so generally the
trading fees are quite low so for mount
gawks the trading fee is 0.6
and so that makes it both ways uh 1.2
percent
and then the trade fees for btc-e
is 0.2 percent so 0.4 both ways but
that's actually quite quite low um
so like with a thousand dollar
investment we're talking with mount gox
your typical trading fees that you might
get
with scottrade or something like that
for stocks but for btc usd now we're
talking about
quite a bit smaller a third of that so
it's very cheap and that's if you're
trading with a thousand dollars
but the beauty of it is you could trade
five dollars worth of bitcoin and you're
only paying a percentage
not a flat uh transaction fee so this
really allows
uh anybody to come into this market and
just trade it just purely for fun which
is kind of what i'm i'm hoping to do
with this series is
is just show you guys that you can
actually play in a real market with
real money so you're dealing with real
emotion and all of that but you're
actually
not i mean you you could put a lot of
money down i wouldn't suggest it for the
reasons that i'm going to get to but
um you know it is a lot of you can have
a lot of fun for
actually pretty cheap so it's kind of
cool
um so that's the volatility aspect to it
but again with the low
since everything is a percentage fee not
an actual dollar fee
it's actually quite nice uh so the next
thing is hacking
um and i say that with you know scare
quotes because no one actually gets
hacked very often these days
um so due to the irreversibility of
bitcoin transactions and they're
unregulated
all of this they make for a very nice
item to steal because there's no legal
help for you
so it becomes pretty difficult to track
anybody especially if they know what
they're doing
if you get your bitcoin stolen i mean
that that's it um
and if you decide to get into trading
bitcoins just
understand that you will be targeted
right so i call this
hacking with scare quotes just because
um again it's it's usually not the case
right so it's more of either social
engineering or just plain outright
fishing
you know you get a phishing email right
that says their mount gox you click on a
link and you log in and no
it's not actually mount gox right um
you're you're just it's like
100 certainty that you're going to get
these phishing emails
um because there's you know two main
exchanges so anybody that knows you deal
with bitcoin knows that you're most
likely on once they have a 50 50 chance
but also most people are on both
exchanges so i mean there
they probably even have higher than a 50
50 percent chance to get it right
so uh keep that in mind
so always you know check links also uh
like i said in the other video i've been
in this sort of business for a very long
time
it's almost always your friend don't
trust your internet friends
okay just be careful and uh hopefully
you won't get all your money stolen
so um not only are you going to see a
lot of phishing links but also don't
download these trading bots i can't
believe some of this stuff that i see in
there
they're like official stuff like i've
even seen some on youtube here where
they have like 20 000 views and 50 likes
right by a brand new account that
clearly bought all of that stuff
don't do it just don't download that
stuff so
maybe at some point i'll show you guys
like how we can program our own trading
both mount gox and btc-e have trading
apis that you can use you just need to
understand encryption
um and a couple other subtleties and
you'll be able to use them so so just
use your own trading api
uh and don't take the risk because it's
you know you you just
if if it says it makes you know a
thousand dollars a day then what the
hell is that guys selling it for and
most of the time they're like a free
download link so
just you know use common sense here uh
the next thing hacking again in quotes
of the website that you use so the
exchange or btc-e or mount gox or
whatever
this is also not uncommon um in the last
few years
even if it's your favorite website again
they can get quote-unquote hacked
usually this is also a social
engineering job um
or just simply a front because the owner
wanted to steal your stuff
and so yeah there's always that next you
have identity theft
along with getting your bitcoin stolen
on most of these trading websites
are going to require personal
information on you for these websites
safety
um but they can easily lose it and also
be selling it on the side for bitcoin
anonymously for
you know no paper trail so so i'll keep
that in mind
uh threat of regulation china just
recently imposed those regulations on
their banks and the usa can
easily follow suit with some legislation
as well
they've been known to to legislate even
if it
goes against these the constitution
so you know you have no idea what to
expect
and at least with usa i mean we're like
you know the government's on record
you know saying that hey we're thinking
about uh doing this because it seems
kind of
it seems just like any other exchange i
wish it is
um so expect that this issue is going to
continue and not only will
and can regulation you know itself cause
trouble
just the threat of regulation can cause
the troubles you know just like uh
quantity
or uh you know like qe2 and all this
stuff uh
just the threat of um taking away that
money causes
massive swings in the market even though
you know it's like oh just kidding we're
not actually gonna do that yeah okay
it's called manipulation anyway
next getting out of the system
uh it's actually very difficult to get
out of the system sometimes especially
for
example u.s and european clients right
now you can just google it yourself and
see how many people are complaining
um about getting their money out of
somewhere like mount gox for example so
you can transfer money into mount gox
and you can transfer money out of mount
gox so you could trade your
you can deposit you know a hundred
dollars uh
convert that to bitcoin trade the
bitcoin a bunch uh
and then you've got maybe uh you know
you did really good and you've got 120
bucks
uh worth of bitcoin you sell the bitcoin
and you want to take your money out
turns out that that takes an indefinite
amount of time i don't know anybody that
has been able to get a
substantial amount of money out of mount
gox and that's very troubling
because
if you time the system right it can
become um
not totally a ponzi scheme but very
close to what a ponzi scheme is so
so to make um withdrawals you're
actually withdrawing someone else's
deposited money and since bitcoin is
just
you know nothingness pretty much um
you can you can kind of cheat the system
uh that way and also mount gox
themselves can be selling their own
bitcoin not really your bitcoin
uh so there's a lot of ways that these
websites could become
just be massive scams also with the in
the recent rises in bitcoin um
that can actually just be a result of
mount gawks not cashing out
people's money right so they're just not
letting people get
out of the market so there's a lot of
money coming into the market
and in theory that money is tied up but
no one can prove that that money is
tied up for real so it could totally be
the case that mount cox
just you know wanted to invest that
money into bitcoin and since bitcoin was
going up so much and now they're trying
to get out of bitcoin
right something like that right and they
just they're not able to make it happen
so
there's always the possibility that
there's um
shenanigans going on
and again with mount gox i mean these
these are relatively new people to the
to the financial industry
you know um and at least with um
with mount gox for example if this is
you and you've got your money stuck in
mount gox just cancel the transaction
take the bitcoin convert that or
transfer that bitcoin to your wallet or
somewhere or somewhere else
uh and then convert it somewhere away
from mount gogs mount gox issue most
likely is the regulation uh
they just recently got in a bunch of
trouble um
for being a financial exchange but not
you know filling out the proper
paperwork to be a financial exchange
here in the u.s
so they're having a lot of trouble there
and so it's either just a cause
of their their laziness uh malfeasance
or something
uh or there is definitely funny business
going on it could be any of those things
really
um like i said before it's always just a
measure of you know how valuable is
their reputation versus how valuable is
the scam you know because
a lot of people don't really have morals
anymore um
so definitely keep your eye out for
mount gox if you are watching this
and you are thinking about going with an
exchange uh keep that in mind that you
might not get your money out of mount
cox
um so yeah so because originally mount
gox really was just you know
number one you know and so that's why
they're still getting a lot of money
pumped into them
but no money is coming out and so you're
just kind of trusting that mount gox
is not using that money it really is
just in float right now
um and i don't really trust them for
that so
anyway uh keep that in mind so
uh so anyway you should definitely you
know do some research on the exchange
that you plan to go with
do some research on btc-e if you want to
go with them do some research on mount
gox it might be the case that mount gox
by the time you
you're viewing this video um has
completely fixed all of their troubles
and they're good to go and to be honest
with you this graph almost looks like
they fixed their troubles
and they lowered their fees or something
anyway um
so those are just some of the basic
risks that you want to keep in mind
because it's kind of easy to
drift into this thinking it's a lot like
stocks or something like that well
with stocks you can easily place trust
in the companies that you're investing
are putting your money in you know so
they're not fdic insured
but you know they're regulated and
they're controlled and they've got
watchdog agencies constantly watching
them but
these companies don't and so there's a
lot of risk involved and so like
here um you know i would just suggest
that
as they usually say right don't invest
with money you can't afford to lose well
i'd take that a step further
and i would say can think of the money
that you're putting into this as money
that you're you're
never going to see again because it's it
the chances of you never ever
wow never ever seeing your money again
the chances of you seeing this money
again
are actually uh low-ish right or not
low-ish but lower than you probably
think
so just keep that in mind that um the
money
you put in there just just do it to have
fun right that's that's kind of the idea
is you can just you know buy five
dollars worth of bitcoin if you want and
play the bitcoin market you know
uh it should just be kind of like fun
learning experience a chance to play in
the market without
um having to put in a sizable amount of
money right
and then maybe you know maybe once you
get comfortable you can consider
uh getting a little more serious uh with
with doing it and look at this mount gox
significantly now holding a price
lower than btc-e we've not seen that in
a long time
uh yeah i wonder what's going on i
have to i have to look after i'm done
here to see what why that's actually
occurring
um anyway uh so that's gonna be the end
of this video as far as risks associated
hopefully i didn't bore you guys too
much but you know this is a real deal
you know if you're thinking of putting
actual money down into this
um it's a lot riskier than i think a lot
of people are realizing and so
i think it's important to uh consider
all the risks
involved so anyway that's going to
conclude this video
in the next video we'll probably be
getting into
some of what we're looking at right now
various trading ideas
um and also where you can get
data like this and maybe even do a
tutorial on the chart itself
a lot of you guys probably recognize
this chart because i've actually
given you guys a tutorial on how to
build this chart pretty much except for
plugging in the prices
so a lot of you guys can probably figure
it out on your own but anyway
maybe a tutorial on that if you want to
see it really badly comment below and
i'll take note
otherwise it might not actually include
a tutorial on how to build this exact uh
chart um but anyway yeah so obviously a
lot there's a lot of interest in the
idea of
arbitrage where you buy you know from
one exchange and you sell on the other
exchange for the profit so like right
now there's only a three dollar or
actually a two dollar spread
um and that's not good enough you need a
quite a bit higher spread but a lot of
times you can see a twenty to thirty
dollars spread
um what we're seeing right now is
actually very
rare at least leading up to this point
um
so i'll be interested to see how this
continues playing out or
why this is playing out um in fact i bet
i could go
see if i can find any information on why
anyway it is fairly um uncommon to see
that
anyway i couldn't find anything on it at
the moment i'm not sure what is
causing this um maybe it's just chance
i don't know uh so i'm gonna go ahead
and conclude the video here
uh anyways hopefully you guys enjoyed
hopefully uh you're interested in this
topic
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support in the subscriptions
and until next time